effectuer son trajet domicile travail
seul dans sa voiture reste une réalité
pour beaucoup de salariés peu écologique
et peu économique la startup WAZ up
cherche à faire bouger les choses en
développant le covoiturage il propose
une application mobile pour mettre en
relation les personnes intéressées par
ce mode de transport ce jeudi il
présentaient leur outil aux salariés du
Technocentre Renault l'application
permet de trouver des coitureurs selon
le trajet souhaité et calculer les frais
réels même lorsque l'on ne finit pas à
une heure fixe chaque jour un système
plus maniable et plus souple que les
sites existants si vous finissez pas
toujours à la même heure le principe
c'est que on crée des petits équipages
de covoiturage où en fait un passager va
avoir plusieurs conducteurs possibles et
via l'application et en quelques
secondes le conducteur dès qu'il sait
qu'il va partir 30 à 40 minutes avant va
pouvoir alerter ses passagers et le
passager va pouvoir se greffer sur le
conducteur qui part à la bonne horire la
société travaille avec des entreprises
partenaires elle paye un forfait pour
offrir se service à leurs salariés et
profitent de reporting élaboré par Wazup
pour leur communication l'application
est d'ors et déjà proposée à plusieurs
entreprises du territoire Renault n'est
plus seul Renault se avec les acteurs
locaux la CaSki mais aussi la snekma
d'autres entreprises ilti bug on se
lance dans cette démarche pour essayer
d'avoir ce qu'on appelle une masse
critique de de covoitureurs potentiel et
qui vont pouvoir partager et créer
une comm deiture Poti pour les salariés
de Renault rencontrés sur place ce
volume ég de coitureur et peut-être la
clé du succès on pouronnaître entre nous
voir les entreprises qui sont vraiment
autour du Technocentre peentu Renault
envisage d'intégrer cette application à
sa tablette Airlink et donc véhicu de la
marque mais il faudra encore quelques
mois pour tester son efficacité